well welcome to our live panel
discussion at the spectator on the
future of british healthcare this
pandemic has shown more clearly than
ever before that our health is not just
determined by our genes but by where we
live how we live our communities and
opportunities and those from poorer
backgrounds or more densely packed
neighborhoods or less healthy diets have
suffered disproportionately from the
last two years
now in the future british healthcare
must take more and more of these
indirect factors into account and in
clinical research too that stage where
the life sciences industry works with
the nhs to develop new medicines and
treatments
too often clinical trials aren't
representative only six percent of those
in covet 19 vaccine trials were from
ethnic minorities for example when 14
of the uk population as a whole are from
black and minority ethnic
groups
there's also an issue of early diagnosis
where conditions like cancer tend to be
found later in the most marginalized
groups of society
all of this has a political salience too
of course as this conservative
government's success or claim to success
is built on the often deprived areas in
the so-called red wall seats
so how can this situation be remedied to
create an nhs that's fit for the future
that's the topic of our discussion today
held in association with and funded by
the pharmaceutical company msd
i'm isabel harbin i'm the assistant
editor at the spectator and i'll be
sharing this discussion i'm joined by dr
louise kenny who is the executive pro
vice chancellor of the faculty of health
and life sciences at the university of
liverpool
chris green is the conservative mp for
bolton west and the vice chair of the
all party parliamentary group for life
sciences and cham herrera is executive
director of medical affairs at msd
welcome to all thank you so much for
joining us
now before you we get started if you're
watching at home on spectator tv you can
send in your questions in the q a tab
just below the video feed
and i'll spend some time going through
them later in the event
so on to the discussion
let me start with you louise i've got a
couple of questions for you but my first
is really for those watching who might
be a little unfamiliar with this
which is what are the life sciences
thanks well i guess the simplest way to
define life sciences um is that it's the
study of all living organisms and the
life processes associated with those
organisms
and those organisms include plants
microbes fungi animals and you know the
very top or one extreme and the and
human beings
um but in the real world we also assume
that life sciences includes the hard
physical sciences that are applied to
those organisms and processes
so by that i mean the pharmaceutical
industry therapeutics and diagnostics
medical devices and all products that
are developed as a side effect of the
life sciences uh in uh industry uh which
are used to treat or aid in the
treatment of patients and animals and
and um
other living things
thank you that's really really helpful i
set out a few numbers in my introduction
but perhaps you could give us an
overview of what health inequality is
like in the uk and whether it's been
getting worse in recent years
well i mean as you said i'm the
executive pro vice chancellor of the
university of liverpool uh the faculty
of health and the university of
liverpool
and i was actually born and raised in
the report and studied medicine in
liverpool
and i studied medicine and worked as a
junior doctor through
the late 80s and early 90s
and even though i grew up in the city i
was
on a daily basis confronted and shocked
by overwhelmingly bad
medical outcomes clinical outcomes
that were disproportionately shared
across the city you know there's a huge
we talk about the north-south divide
nationally but there is a north-south
divide across our city
um and back in the 90s there there was a
differential in terms of uh overall um
life uh life course survival um a sort
of difference of 12 years
between women who were born in the south
of the city and those that were born in
the north of the city
i left liverpool in 1997 and came back
four years ago to a leadership role and
i was dismayed to find that those
indices haven't really budged at all
despite the uh the fact that liverpool
is now prospering in a way that it
hasn't done for more than a century
the the health inequalities have
remained firmly um
and very unfortunately wedged baked in
into into floor city
and i think our city is just a you know
a representative for a small um
representative of what's happening
across uh the north nationally we have
huge inequalities um between the north
and south of our of our country and also
between um urban and rural areas and
particularly bad outcomes in some of the
northern coastal areas
and that's that's you know we're a small
country um and i find that um inequality
quite perplexing it seems to be largely
driven by you know a mix a mixture of
um a mixture of drivers but i think it
all does come down to um poverty in its
widest sense and and in the 21st century
i think that's that's quite quite
unfortunate
chris green just tell us a little bit
about your experience as an mp does that
chime with what we've just heard from
louise
i think so it's um
i think as society has become more
mobile people
will move for work
and people will
like birds and feather collect together
so if people are highly qualified highly
skilled very well paid then they'll move
to similar areas and actually because
that has happened over many decades you
get these concentrations increasing
concentrations of wealthy people in one
area poorer people in another area
and and it's all the other things that
uh uh go with it as well so um
so i think that's one of the the key
aspects why it's so difficult to bridge
this divide and
obviously national government is uh
incredibly important on this but also
local government as well
and it's very difficult for national
government to
drive this because
fundamentally you can have a
one-size-fits-all
approach and i do think in terms of the
uh
health and
white paper having the integrated care
systems that to some extent this is what
the government wants to do wants to
resolve by having the actual leadership
within the health and care system far
closer to the people
okay and
cham i mentioned in my introduction some
of the inequalities in clinical research
what's your experience of that and
what's your experience of that in the
pandemic
yeah
firstly thank you for allowing us to
sponsor this and um it's great to be
such a informed eminent sort of uh panel
i i i think louise and chris have
already alluded to the divide and
especially i think uh what chris said
there is is that we have cities across
the uk now more
which have that that inequality you know
one side of the city uh is has a social
deprivation and poor health outcomes and
other parts are affluent and have better
outcomes and usually the hospital or the
healthcare system treating both
populations is the same and therefore
the one size fits all that we've seen
historically being applied as an
efficient method of delivering
innovation is probably not the wrong
what the right way to go and we need a
better i suppose thinking at a local
level in how do you implement innovation
and access and let's not forget we we
have
over the
last 15 years being a country that has
adopted in innovation right so we should
be having better health outcomes and
we've always had a great sort of
clinical and scientific sort of research
community that is world leading in lots
of different therapy areas and hence the
reason why companies like ours like to
invest in the uk and work and
collaborate with the uk so so what we've
seen um throughout is not only has covid
and and the treatments for kovid
highlighted these disparities in
inequalities but also for the disease
areas that have had to
almost take a back seat to allow
patients with kobe to be treated have
also
been
expanded in in their in their uh
uh i suppose inequalities so cancer
being one of the key ones that that
is easy to identify i mean we we know
from the headlines from last year and
the year before about over 25 000 in in
a case being missed but also when you
look at sort of the new additional cases
that are being diagnosed saying lung
cancer and esophageal cancer 30 of those
are being driven 30 000 of those have
been driven by the fact that they are
based on on social inequality factors
that drive those incidences so
the the the separation is not just about
access to health care it is actually
driving the incidence of poor health in
in individuals so so it's something that
we need to address and i think
um the covered experience has given us
some insights into how we may approach
that but at the same time i think it has
left us in a situation where there is a
lot of catch-up to be done to get back
to where we were prior to the pandemic
one of the
areas i think
one of the areas i think that has been
revealed by the
pandemic and
you're the educational divide
one of the key aspects of that is
children's access to devices a good
internet connection at home and places
where they can learn so that's a
challenging start for people's lives
and that's so important for what comes
on down the line but in terms of uh what
we're looking back uh looking at in
terms of medical advances
there's a lot more in terms of what
people can do themselves and managing
their own health and there's a big
question over that uh who was most able
uh to be able to manage their own health
to understand what they're doing why
they're doing it and uh be able to
access the understanding and the
technology to be able to do that and it
goes into that whole narrative
understanding about the digital divide
in our society so perhaps the people who
are already advantaged will be able to
take more advantage of the potential
that comes down with these advanced
advances
when you say people who are able to
manage their own health
i think one of the reactions that people
listening might have is is oh does that
mean people who the nhs doesn't need to
bother with just just explain a little
bit more about what you mean there
it's um
there is so much more um that can and
should be done for example just
um
having the right technology if you're
wearing a piece of technology that
monitors your heart rhythm and you go
about your normal daily life
the fact that you can upload or have uh
the system perhaps of
technologies monitoring it artificial
intelligence you can actually assess
people's health care on a daily basis
that can then be transmitted
back into the system
and therefore you've got a far better
way of appreciating someone's
health and when and where they have
actual problems now if someone can
engage with and use that technology
and have those conversations with the
doctors and what they're doing how
they're going about their lives
that relationship actually enhances the
ability for the medical profession to
support uh them and their healthcare
when you get into more
complicated areas as we come down the
line i
i think that challenge if people aren't
educated in the right way are given the
right support
uh their ability to actually have that
ongoing relationship with the profession
as opposed to being told take these
pills go home i'll see you in a month's
time
fantastic
louise how easy is it for the nhs to to
move to to this kind of model i mean we
we do know that uh was it a tenth of all
uh nhs trusts are still largely
paper-based so this sounds like quite
quite a leap for quite a few of them
it it it is and it and it will be but um
if um if there are any advantages and i
strongly you know i strongly believe
there are no advantages to having a
pandemic but one of the things that's
come out of the covid19
pandemic is that it has driven home
and that we are amidst us a data and
technological revolution um but our ways
of working perhaps haven't responded to
it as agility as perhaps they should
um and digital exclusion digital poverty
uh particularly in areas that are
already um etched out as having um
unequal unmet health needs is a key is a
key barrier
um
so i i think there is there is both a
challenge and an opportunity uh wrapped
up in one that how do we how do we move
everyone's heard the expression that
data is the new oil and personally i
think that's a really unfortunate
analogy because for a variety of reasons
i think data is far more enduring and
far more valuable than oil and also
nowhere near as toxic but
um as we move to to really exploiting
that we've got an infrastructure that
does not allow us to be as our job as we
can um you know if you look at some of
the scandinavian countries they are way
ahead of us in terms of what they can do
with their health data because they have
a collective approach they've they've
been very sort of they've future-proofed
um their healthcare systems they have
and they've grown a culture of um
of a community and acceptance that
people um
expect that their health data will be
used for the greater good of society we
haven't even really outlined those
principles yet and we certainly haven't
adopted them as a country and that's
really holding us back if you think
about you know just even the north of
england
we have if we if we network some of our
key areas across the north we'd have 16
million people
now that's a huge population that's
literally on our doorstep it is
unfortunately a population with
significant
health needs significant disease levels
what we could do with that data would
surpass anything that's coming out of
the much smaller scandinavian countries
just in terms of statistical power but
we've been really slow to harness uh
that potential fortunately as i say i
think the covid19 pandemic has actually
illustrated what we can do when we think
creatively and we are agile and there
are now several really exciting
initiatives uh that are in play that i
think will will accelerate um
our journey towards that ambition
including um you know the onset of sifa
the uh the integrated healthcare system
for population health in the north which
which i think will you know will be a
huge engine for innovation and will
provide key answers um but you know on
the ground work west we've still got a
long way to go
i bet you have a perspective on how good
the nhs is at uh innovation and
technology yeah no i mean i i totally
agree with louise i mean i think when i
started out in this industry about 18
years ago when we were approaching and
maybe introducing a new medicine to
treat a particular disease you know a
lot the initial stuff was just trying to
understand what is the extent of that
disease in the uk and it was very
difficult back then you'd have to go to
different part you know groups and
collaborate and and try to you know put
cobble the data together right
what has changed over the last 18 years
is that there are better systems in
place in the nhs but as louise pointed
out
we still haven't addressed the
principles of how do we access that data
how do we uh analyze that data and then
utilize it to inform health uh
healthcare provision
and we're still struggling in the
pharmaceutical industry with the same
problems of of looking for collaborators
and partners to say look we need to
better understand the demographics of
lung cancer in manchester or so forth
and how do we do that
but there have been great examples of of
digitization and trying to think out out
of the box so to speak so for example
salford you know
along with uh one of our
competitive companies jsk you know put
together salford lung studies some years
ago which digitized the records
at both primary care and in a hospital
setting of all the patients in that
region so it allowed
to be able to follow that individuals
from the primary care gp setting into
their hospitals and get a better
understanding of the challenges of a
given disease and especially in this
case it was a
lung disease and and um issues there and
then we've also got something called the
crpd database which has been going for
some years now which has over 30 million
records of of
individuals anonymized that can be
utilized for research and they are now
joined up with hospital debt so we have
got it and i i do always get annoyed
when when um sweden example's brought up
right because actually sweden hasn't
done anything more different and we've
have the same infrastructure in place to
be able to do exactly what sweden and
other some of the other scandinavian
countries do
and all we just need is just a
centralized cohesive approach and some
principles in place you know and i think
um to safeguard you know
the control of that data should remain
within the nhs uh and within academia
and then i think we have a system in
place currently where you can you know
apply to to do research with that data
in anonymized fashion which protects the
individual but also still maintains
control of where that data goes to and
how that data is utilized so
it'd be good to see that but you know
and as louis said i think the pandemic
has
moved us along a bit but but
you know it remains to be seen whether
that lasts in into the endemic phase
well i think it's how style at the
spectators mentioned sweden as often as
possible but uh so thank you for that
chris one of the questions i have is uh
we talked about the pandemic in some
senses uh speeding things up giving us a
greater awareness of changes that the
nhs needs to make
but your party is reorganizing the nhs
uh again having done it 10 years ago
does this not slow things down or is the
the new health and care bill actually
going to be the great technological and
innovative panacea that the health
service has been waiting for for 75
years
well it has a
potential to do that whether we realize
that potential is a
very different matter
i
i think the
there's a broad consensus that the
uh lansley reforms didn't quite deliver
what they are supposed to and that that
does need to be some uh reversing of
aspects
of that one of the problems is um as a
broad uh uh problem with uh government
is so much of the power is put at la
arms length organizations and when
something happens ministers have to make
decisions and they can't they're held to
account for uh what is going on but they
don't have the authority or the ability
to
demand that things have done they have
to work in a very slow way through the
system and
that with respect to nhs england
as a whole as well because the bill does
give the secretary of state a deal more
so that is part of it uh drawing uh
power back to the secretary of state to
have more of a decisive uh
decision-making process
but
i think for people outside the nhs or
outside of the life science sector
people would look at the nhs and think
this is our national health system it
must be integrated it must work together
whether it's the gp
working with the hospital trust it all
must function as an entity and be
coherent it isn't it's a very long way
uh from it and it is quite interesting
uh as as was mentioned about salford uh
in the conversations i have with uh
different groups the number of times
that as a local mp in bolton it's just
down the road the number of times i hear
salford brought up because fundamentally
i think that's about that leadership in
salford it's about how they
lead how they work with other
organizations
institutes from around the country also
i think that relationship with the
private sector ought to be more
fundamental more engaged and the nhs
data is a huge resource very sensitive
politically and very sensitive about how
an individual's data is used so the
point about having anonymized data is
immensely important but that resource
that i think many people will be happy
for the nhs happy for
universities other organizations to use
in a very controlled way
but that should be
used and made available for
more and better research to really take
on um
the challenges because
people are demanding more and more
better health care and one of the
aspects of that is the easy or the the
big diseases or the big conditions have
by and large got pretty good treatments
and you're increasing increasingly going
to the territory of rare diseases or
more difficult diseases you therefore
need larger bodies of people
for your studies so this is on a uk wide
and this is internationally as well so
these relationships these collaborations
are key and actually the national health
service doesn't meet the expectations
that people would recently have
louise you were nodding away in in that
we've we've had sweden we've had salford
you've got another location preferably
beginning with an s that you want uh
sadly no but um i do i there's two
points i do want to just pick up on
because i i think they are worth just
sort of hammering home so i think the
current round of nhs reforms um present
an unprecedented sort of
once-in-a-generation opportunity really
that at the moment i'm concerned we're
we're not going to exploit
and that's really to embed r d at the
heart of the nhs
i i you know i've sort of combed the
bill from from uh start to finish and
i've looked at the mouss that underpin
uh the 30-yard ics's from cumbria down
to the silly owls and i was that's
memorandums of understanding the
memorandum of understanding yeah
care systems yeah so i'm an nhs person
so we're very good at speaking in
acronyms and jargon
but i was quite disappointed that's why
many of my colleagues in the sector
really just to see that research was
really not not embedded in the bill and
and nor was it really reflected in the
memorandums of understanding um and i'm
part of a group
of colleagues and entities across the
sector now that it includes the medical
schools council the associated medical
charities uh
and a variety of people you know and
funders who are really asking to just
pause and see if we can actually embed
um
or encourage in some way mandate for
research um
to be core business for the nhs and the
reason for that is very simple um
you know when we talk about um health
inequality uh and adverse health
outcomes across the uk and why they vary
so much one of the dr you know it's very
simplistic and in fact i think it's
overly simplistic to say it's social
exclusion or poverty one of the reasons
why um
outcomes are not as good as they could
be is that research is often not
actually performed where patients are
sick so if you look at oxford and
cambridge uh you know that absolutely
don't get me wrong the research coming
out of those organizations are amazing
it's amazing but actually um most of the
sick people are in blackpool they're in
liverpool they're in newcastle um
and and
r d spend is really disproportionate
across the country there's an inverse
proportion you know there's an inverse
um
uh relationship there and so i think
we've got an opportunity to embed or
mandate or encourage um rdi activity
within the new within the new nhs post
reforms by making it someone's
responsibility that you know it's not
just nice to have it's not just
something we do in the margins of our
day jobs or when we've got time because
quite frankly you know in the nhs
there's never time and there are no
margins but we make it core activity and
apart from you know apart from the fact
that that would be an enormous
contribution to leveling up i mean i
mean it would level up in
a huge way it will also have a really
profound effect on patient outcomes we
know from work done in a you know a
variety of different healthcare systems
all over the world that the single most
independent thing you can do to improve
health outcomes is to offer the
opportunity to take part in research
because if you're taking part in
research you're either going to get the
standard of care or possibly the next
best thing and we know time after time
in a variety of healthcare settings in a
variety of countries but if you are
being cared for in a research um rich
environment
then your outcomes are on average 30
percent better 30 i mean that's massive
and so i think we do have um
this huge opportunity and and
frustratingly it's not about funding
although you know as an academic i'd
always welcome more funding it's mainly
about making research and you know core
business and not nice to have
um and i think you know we we do have
this unique opportunity partly because
the act is uh in play at the moment and
also because you know if not now in the
post-pandemic recovery era when we've
never been more attuned to the impact
that research can have on health
outcomes than when you know i absolutely
have always believed that um life
sciences can be a central plank of the
leveling up agenda but it's also going
to be an absolute central pla plank of
our inclusive recovery from covert and i
think the the key word there is
inclusive
canada i mean i i i wholeheartedly agree
and i think from our from our
pharmaceutical perspective it's exactly
that leveling up that that would achieve
that is really important because it
would allow us to provide access through
clinic the clinical study framework for
the most that need across the uk for new
things as louise said you know these
these studies have done our standard of
care versus the next best thing right so
so obviously it isn't still without risk
but at least the individuals in all
those localities will have the
opportunity to make an informed choice
of do i go into that study and and and
tried out so so that's what's missing
today and i think
louise touch upon it there is what we
have is it is a is academic research is
polarized from from clinical uh delivery
and i think you know what we we do have
this opportunity to marry those together
across
the uk currently and and therefore we
have
we won't be in this artificial thing or
which we currently have which we we
generate the data of clinical efficacy
and safety of a given drug it's assessed
by bodies like nice and so forth then
the nhs has to work out how is is that
it deployed right so if you're doing
studies uh in in across the board in in
especially in those areas most at need
you will have the the the variety and
diversity of population of people coming
into those studies but moreover as
you're doing the studies you can work
out what the clinical
delivery of that particular therapeutic
intervention should be like going
forward and we've seen some of those
examples in the pandemic you know with
with studies that are being created but
it is an opportunity and i do worry like
louise that that we may lose that
opportunity uh uh you know because we've
been here before historically but not to
this extent you know where i think all
parties are aligned on what we need to
achieve
chris just to come back to you on some
of the points that have been made about
the legislation i wonder whether firstly
whether you agree uh with what louise
and chandler said but also whether
practically
what could change i mean there's been a
lot of debates uh around the bill as
you'd expect with anything to do with
the nhs around the role of private
companies and you know whether they
should be allowed to uh sit on
integrated care boards for instance do
you think there should be a greater
representation for r d on those boards
uh how could the leadership of
integrated care systems uh
ensure that r d is part of the sort of
ethos of that area i wonder what your
thoughts are on that
i in the uh the bill itself the the
language is so
vague uh
any integrated uh care system can have
as much or pretty much as little uh uh
relationship with uh r d or
innovation as it likes so the
requirements almost not there
um
so that does come down to leadership of
the 40 or so the 40-plus
integrated systems around the country
who sits on those boards uh what makeup
you have in terms of officials from the
nhs or the wider health system uh
business
industry universities those who are more
focused on the r d side of things and to
get that culture shift now my
expectation wouldn't be that every
single
integrated cast system is going to be a
leading
innovator or will have those amazing
relationships with the sector but i
would hope and i would expect that's
sufficient of them perhaps maybe a
relatively small number but sufficient
of them do and they become the leaders
and they become those role model
organizations that others
can and will and have that pressure that
demand perhaps from the secretary of
state but also i think from the bottom
up if we can have more clarity
over health outcomes in a particular
area and more ability to demand from
those leaders who sit on the board what
are you doing uh what are you achieving
how you're engaging to deliver these
better services why is the neighboring
uh system so far ahead in one particular
area perhaps we're
ahead and worn we're behind in others
how do we make sure we
level up um in all sectors and i think
there will be individual areas
um that will lead will take take take
the lead and it to some extent it goes
back to that point uh about salford why
is it how is it that particular
uh hospital trust uh gathers
and creates that culture that perhaps
then draws more people in who think
i could work in a number of different
places now why do i want to work here or
here well i know if i
uh i'm interested i i've done my medical
degree i've done my phd whatever it
might be if i want to take it up to the
next level if i want the huge
opportunities this is the trust or this
is the integrated care system i want to
work at
i think i think right in that we can't
expect all of the integrated care
systems or partnerships to
to be you know at the forefront of our
rdi much as that would be which is that
would be wonderful i think it's a
completely unrealistic expectation my
worry is that um those that are
currently succeeding which are largely
clustered in the golden triangle will
continue to flourish and succeed and yet
the majority of patients that we're
talking about who are currently excluded
from research because
it's not happening on their doorstep in
the localities where they live and
unfortunately die prematurely
that won't change and yet we do have
universities across the north of england
who are you know willing and ready and
able to take part but
there's no there's no incentive there's
no encouragement you know we're locked
out of that process you know i think the
language is fake but a small tweak to
the language to sort of encourage that
in areas where there is for example a
russell group university and a medical
school they should be part of the
integrated care system they should be
part of the the culture that says you
know we're here and where we have a lot
to offer in terms of our our life
sciences rdi and and
and the the communities that we seek to
serve you know across the north we have
great red brick civic universities and
the emphasis there is on civic we we we
seek to serve the population that we are
embedded in
but at the moment we're you know in some
ways
we're we're effectively
uh at best not incentivized to do that
and at worst we're actually sort of
blocked out of it so
i think
it would be great if there could be some
sort of central incentivization or
guidance because i'm really concerned
that without that
we'll we'll migrate into the you know
the after the act into a new normal and
that will look very much like the old
normal where there is a large cluster of
activity and funding
in in areas that do research excellence
but are absolutely remote from the
majority of people who are sick and need
access to
research
sorry
go go ahead go ahead i'll jump in
you know okay um what was i going to say
sorry
is i i totally agree with what you said
and louis said but i also think that
going back to your comments about
lansley i think there was one thing in
the lands division for the nhs which was
more to empower the patient and hear the
patient voice i don't think that's
really occurring i think as these ics's
are created as well as
being inclusive at the board level of
research and everything else they must
prioritize hearing from those
communities and and louise i totally
agree with you i mean some population is
really difficult to access but they
should be incentivized to hear from them
and get that i mean we at msd i mean to
solve on the diversity inclusion
problems for clinical studies actually
went into students from diverse
communities and said here's our problem
so they're not subject matter experts
about running clinical studies but we
said our problem is we're not attracting
people in so what do you think and and
and the wealth of recommendations and
ideas was
a you know a ball me over and moreover
we are implementing those uh this year
so so i think definitely getting that
patient voice and the population voice
rather
in the area is really critical for the
success of ics's and also understanding
how to implement a given pathway
chris i think the the northern health
and uh northern health science alliance
uh they've highlighted or report a
northern life sciences super cluster and
so i think there is uh uh some work
there is some focus on this and i as a
conservative i instinctively like market
forces but also
uh the leveling of agenda led by michael
gove i don't know what's going to be in
the report
uh the white paper that's coming out in
a couple of weeks or so in terms of
leveling up but i would hope i'd expect
life sciences uh to be part of that
especially as the government's got that
ambition to increase percentage of gdp
uh spend on r d to take up to 2.4
by 2027 a significant part of that has
to be
in this area and to have the uk focus
just in the golden triangle i think is a
problem now we need to be competitive to
make sure that uh industry and
collaboration works in the uk we need to
be globally competitive and so we ought
not to be undermining them but to have
so much concentrated in one section of
the country i think whether it's the
clinical trials those relationships that
researchers can have
with whether it's universities or
whether it's the
uh
gps or local hospitals you've got to
have that and therefore having a second
hub
uh in the north of england ideally and
i'll be thinking liverpool manchester us
or south lancashire north cheshire would
be
got slight buyers from liverpool uh
worked in manchester for a long time um
but having that second concentration and
this is where leveling up fundamentally
has to be an intervention recognizing
that market forces haven't delivered
and we in the uk are actually
underplaying our strengths and by having
that second hub actually i think it'll
be mutually beneficial
to both
fantastic well we have got loads of
questions uh from the audience thank you
to everyone who's been sending them
through
so we're gonna we're gonna move to a
discussion of those questions and i
think a really good one to start on
comes from tim who asks what is a life
sciences superpower what measures or
metrics does the government need to
set and achieve to meet this
aim louise let's start with you on that
question
yeah so a life sciences superpower well
i mean we we are fortunate um in england
and that we have some of the most um
prolific world-leading life sciences uh
superpowers and clusters uh you know and
and for my talk as a northern girl about
the golden triangle i am super proud of
what's come out of both the cambridge
science park
and the oxford cluster particularly
during the pandemic uh you know we've
made uh we've had a huge global impact
uh in terms of uh our diagnostics and
our vaccine work
and uh you know we just mentioned the
northern health science alliance i'm on
the board of the northern health science
alliance and i think you know across the
north we're now working collaboratively
to pool our resources
which are complementary and yet very
different as you look from the west to
the east coast to to come together as
one showcasing to the world to the
country and the world actually that we
have a diverse and yet collectively you
know world class uh life sciences
capability it's spread acro across a
wide geography but actually when you
cluster it together we are um punching
way above our weight
in terms of of how we you know what sort
of metrics you apply i mean as a
clinician i'm always going to come back
to things that make a hard difference to
to health outcomes but they are they're
not just the traditional health outcomes
that we think of you know in terms of
you know crude indices of mortality and
morbidity i think you know as we move
into the the this century and further
into this century and we look at some of
the other challenges um we can now look
at how you know the interaction between
things like how we are mitigating the
inevitable impact of climate change on
health
how we are and perhaps how life sciences
clusters superclusters actually level up
you know it's no good exceeding in terms
of winning health outcomes in one area
if it's not if you don't share the joy
and
you know
as a woman i'm also particularly
concerned about how women as a whole
have been left behind in in this in this
endeavor and you know i'm delighted to
see the women's health strategy coming
to the fore this year because i think
that that's a huge step forward from
this government in terms of of how we
can address that
um and then there's also you know the
and this will be central to our post
economic post covered economic recovery
plan
um uh hard metrics like rdi activity uh
in investment in
inward investment into the country and
and how we are also generating um you
know high value jobs and generating not
just the high value jobs but also
educating people with the right skills
across the country to fill those high
value jobs so that you know there's a
there's a
catalog of metrics you could apply
um but i think we need to think a little
bit more um
you know in a looser sense about what
what good looks like and and how we
measure it
fantastic thank you
uh chris what are your aspirations for a
life sciences superpower i wonder
whether i mean the description that
louise has just given us makes me feel
like we already are as a country
and yet it doesn't seem to be part of
our identity in the way that you know
the nhs is
well i think um
listening to colleagues in parliament uh
those who are
uh based in cambridgeshire uh
london
they are far more likely to talk about
uh the r d side of things the life
sciences sector to a certain extent
because the such dominant industries in
that part of the united kingdom and
therefore by being so concentrated in
those areas and mps are very responsive
uh to concerns and interests in their
constituency by being in one corner of
the united kingdom
i don't think it's discussed and raised
as much
uh in parliament and more widely
therefore having a better geographic
spread i think will give that awareness
uh and that interest to some extent in
uh people growing up going through
school uh getting their education going
through training and actually to see the
opportunities to see actually if i focus
my education in the sector because i've
got opportunities uh close by rather
than having to go uh travel to 300 miles
to get that
good job but it's not just those
top-level academics it's also
technicians and other people who perhaps
wouldn't travel
quite so far for those opportunities i
think it's the educational side that uh
understanding side is
immensely important but an aspect i
would like to see uh well two aspects
i'd like to see far more of
is the national health service can be
pretty slow sometimes adopting new
technologies whether it's uh from the
pharmaceutical sector whether it's
medical devices we can be
pretty slow in comparison to germany and
france adopting these uh new
technologies so i'd like to see that
advance but also i i often will
occasionally reflect on
uh the other end of the r d uh process
the actual manufacturing side i think
the uh astrozenica uh factory in
macclesfield is uh its production is
worth about one percent of the uk's uh
export value so if we can have more
factories as well the r d at the
beginning the collaborations in the nhs
but also uh the manufacturing side as
well i think people would see
increasingly that life science sector is
where you can get a good job uh a
well-paid a highly skilled job and
actually it'll be a huge benefit to the
country and that's so i don't know about
definition of a superpower but i'd like
to see that beginning middle and end in
the uk
damn
i i mean what i've got to add to that i
think and louise and chris have sort of
alluded to this is i think any metrics
we apply have to apply to the whole
pathway right so it's from metrics about
how google are with the research how
good we are at the manufacturing and
then the health outcomes and then also
the implementation so so it's no good
just to look at the health outcomes and
say well we've improved those because
actually that that doesn't allude to it
and whilst we have got great examples
and and i used to be medical director at
az chris so you're right it's one
percent of gdp but but actually when you
look at the manufacturers and the
vaccines the large proportion happens
outside of the uk the pandemic so so we
should be looking at how do we reverse
that in terms of being able to have
those capabilities and i think chris had
mentioned it it's part of that is
awareness and you ask the question right
at the top isabel about what is life
sciences right so so we need to foster
that education as well about
different areas and and you know
for example ics boards understanding
what it's about and the opportunities it
can bring from our perspective so we are
investing i mean uh companies like
ourselves um are investing we're you
know building a new life sciences
discovery center
but what we find is actually to spread
across the uk is very difficult because
in certain areas the infrastructure
doesn't exist and i think you know for
me i think it's having a
a consistent and and uh
infrastructure available in these
different hubs to be able to do it
thank you very much let's go to a
question from aj which is which
hospitals best blend research and
medical treatment and what can be learnt
from them
charm let's stick with you
so so what i can say is um
you know the from our perspective and i
know you know i i trained it some areas
which is imperial now so those ones and
learn teaching hospitals as general tend
to be the better ones at integrating
both simply because i think the the
academic and the research part is better
integrated into the clinical part so you
have departments that deliver clinical
health care that isn't devoid of
academic individuals that also sees in
that department so so and therefore
things like outpatient clinics and so
forth are run with one eye of of those
people in the outpatients understanding
which clinical studies are are running
that are relevant to that patient
population being seen in that clinic so
for me i think
it is probably teaching hospitals i
wouldn't you know
go further than trying to pick out
individual hospitals or so forth but but
i think you know where you see the
successes is where there is that
cohesion where all staff members
understand what the clinical research
priorities are for that hospital and
what they're involved in from that
perspective and i think that's where
then in each consultation you have that
discussion with a patient say look i can
treat you like this because this is a
nice approved treatment however we do
have a study that is doing this and i
think you know that's what we say um and
you know liverpool you know manchester
you know are great examples as well
being you know great seats of teaching
hospitals and academia
chris you mentioned salford
earlier uh yes so i i'd normally um uh
highlight salford because so many people
do
raise it but it's not necessarily about
every
uh hospital or every trust being sulfur
around the country it's also about the
participating
participation uh so you might have the
uh very academic um
elements concentrated perhaps in certain
trusts but how do other hospitals how do
gps relate to that how do they connect
because
a great deal of it is about awareness
and having these conversations and
saying
you come to our gp uh sergio you'll come
to our hospital but we're aware
of this collaboration we're aware of
this treatment we're aware of this
alternative we're aware perhaps of
rather than you coming in all the time
what about this technology you can take
home
all of these things i think by having
that complimentary approach people
can access it more because the system is
more engaged now how do you get how do
you
um get a hospital or a gp who already
say they're overworked they can barely
cope with what they have to do at the
moment how do you get them to
participate in that way and i think
that's a huge challenge
and um
i don't think i i can answer it at the
moment but that's one of the the big
challenges in terms of this uh
participation but you we have to
break this kind of just about coping
mentality we have to break into that to
make sure you can create a more virtuous
circle where uh you have better
technology better treatment uh that
frees up money that frees up time to
enable some of that time then to be
spent on these um
more um r d led or innovative led uh
processors
louise what do you make both of that
question and of of chris's point there
about uh ensuring that there's actually
capacity to do this work
yeah and i i fundamentally agree that
capacity is a huge thing and i also
agree with chris in that you know
in a in a truly integrated system there
will be those that that do and generate
and those that just offer the
participation because we know we can't
all be world-class experimental medicine
but i fundamentally believe that the
trials that result from that um
experimental medicine should be offered
you know nationally to everyone no one
should be excluded
and and that you know it means that
inclusive looks being inclusive doesn't
necessarily mean that everyone does the
same thing
but i also agree with charm that in
general
uh the hospitals uh or the institutes in
which
rdi is delivered at its best in the uk
are in those university hospitals that
are affiliated to the medical schools
traditionally and in the in the latest
or most recent iteration that's kind of
been recognized the most high performing
of those organizations have been
recognized with uh
academic health science center
designation and that in turn the you
know the concept of an academic health
science center
um really sort of sprung out of um
amongst other places the karolinska
institute where you know the karolinska
is hand in glove a university in a
hospital but the two are seamless um you
know you're in the university but you're
in the hospital and it doesn't make a
difference between the two because they
are one entity
and the minute you walk through the door
of the karolinska
it is it's not just you know research is
just not expected it's going to happen
because you're in a you know a
completely research saturated
environment and i think you know that's
that's what we aspire to and we're a
long you know we're a long way
on that journey now mainly thanks to the
foresight of sally davis and the
inception of um
of nihr and the massive difference that
nihr funding nhr is an entity in nhr
in terms of its funding capacity is made
to
medical sciences life sciences medical
sciences research
uh in our country you know i i'm going
to say this i would say this there's you
know lots done more to do but when i
think about what the um life sciences
rdi funding landscape was like when i
left the uk in 2006
and then i compared it to what it was
like when i came back in 2017 it has
been transformed by nihr you know now
we've taken a challenge recently with
covert and i think you know nihr in the
wash up will have been shown to be one
of the key differentials in terms of
what we did good in the pandemic um and
i i'm really excited for what comes next
you know and if if um
if uh if we can increase that um
you know the rdi spend you know in terms
of gdp to to those ambitious levels i
think the future looks really bright so
yeah i i think you know academic health
science centers and we could do with a
few more of them we'd certainly love one
in liverpool
it's really nice to hear somebody saying
they're excited about the future after
this pandemic and actually about the way
that this pandemic can affect
um
affect life sciences and research in a
positive way but i guess one of my
questions off the back of what we've
just said we've you know we've talked
about capacity we've talked about
uh changing the way that hospitals
operate
is the nhs has a huge backlog uh you
know record backlog to deal with its
staff are exhausted it's not just a case
of vacancies and uh you know enough
people to carry out the work the people
who are there are also really struggling
so
it is now really the time when change is
going to happen
louise yeah i mean
it is a it's a i think it's a really
good question um but i think you know if
we can if the change reduces um
increases efficiency reduces a little
bit of redundancy um and
uh increase it you know increases the
way with that we can perform in an agile
setting then now now is a perfect time
to do it because of those capacity
issues so it's i think it's not without
risk and i you know i won't rehearse the
concerns i've got again about the missed
opportunity that the bill represents in
terms of you know taking some of the
learnings from the pandemic and
embedding rdi activity um but i think if
we can you know increase efficiency
reduce a little bit of redundancy and
actually
uh you know adopt agility
uh nationwide then then i think it's it
will be you know
surely only good can come from it
but it's it's not without risk
okay
let's move on to another question from
um
uh actually i don't know who this is
from so thank you whoever it was from
because it's very good question
why does health only involve healing and
not enough emphasis on prevention we'll
go to you first chris
um
well i think there's increasingly a
focus on this this uh this aspect of
maintaining people's health rather than
repairing people afterwards
and so no doubt there's historic reasons
for it
um
and this ought to be a requirement and
that every of uh every structure in the
national health service ought to have
more emphasis on but i i suspect one of
the reasons why it's quite challenging
is the the funding model that's used at
the moment if a particular department uh
spends its resources
uh in one area create savings it doesn't
actually necessarily create the savings
for itself and therefore isn't motivated
uh perhaps to uh have the probably the
best intervention uh so having a smarter
funding system where
if you
perhaps put some more money in uh you
innovate you try to protect people's
health rather than let them become ill
and then treat them afterwards but
actually your funding
is protected or your mechanism your your
ability to do that is protect so i think
that's what one of the aspects
is the
the nhs hasn't in that sense evolved its
model or it evolved its approach to
treating people
and
this might be one of those areas where
the integrated health systems can be far
more flexible and within that system
within that framework i can uh
more manage those fundings but i i
fundamentally think an aspect of it
there's cultural shifts uh but unless
the funding model's right uh it's going
to be very difficult to do that
can i come in there yet
i do agree with chris that you know it's
um there are no
there are multiple aspects to it and
it's not easy but
i i think just taking a helicopter view
prevention prevention is really hard
you know so if we just take and i i i
come to this with a huge amount of bias
because i'm a women's health researcher
you know my day job is an obstetrician
and i my research is in women's health
and outcomes
but if we take if we just take um
the standard nhs cardiology clinic and
that we'll see you know in the course of
an afternoon maybe 60 patients with
cardiac disease much of which might be
atherosclerotic you know coronary artery
disease
we know that about 50 of that disease
burden actually originates in the first
1000 days of life and yet it doesn't
manifest until five decades later
and so that makes prevention really
really hard because for every every
pound you spend now you're not actually
going to see the benefits possibly for
three four five decades and in a
pressured funding environment there are
short-term
you know much more you know um
burning platforms that need to be
attended to
and i also think that what feeds this is
because you know everyone and everyone
is the result of a pregnancy and how
about pregnancy and that you know as i
say those first 1000 days ago
actually will determine your life course
in a really profound way you know
probably fifty percent of disease burden
if not more and certainly in some
disease areas that the the the nurture
but the first one thousand days is far
more influential
and yet we do have this disparity in
terms of funding um and also rdi and
women you know you will have seen that
we've all seen a lot of coverage
recently about the fact that women are
often excluded from clinical trials
pregnant women are all excluded from
almost all research and we've come a
long way in the last few decades from
recognizing that actually we're not
protecting women by doing that we're
actually creating uh huge health
inequalities by excluding women from
research
and we've even seen that with the
vaccine research recently so you know
prevention is hard it takes time and the
um the outcomes are a slow burn and i
think what feeds into a lot of health
inequalities that could that have their
roots you know could be potentially
prevented is the fact that the time to
prevent them is in pregnancy and early
infancy and research and funding has
just been absent from that area for the
best part of the last century um and
that's why you know i mentioned it
earlier i was so delighted to see the
women's health strategy and because
although that's about women's health
outcomes in the rounds you know the core
of that is about rdi as well so
um that that's another aspect of it
and just just to add to that i'm sorry
just let you add in but i just want to
have my own question as well which is
that the point that louise is making is
quite a challenging one for
pharmaceutical companies because the the
reason that preg women aren't uh
included in trials is ethical reasons
and i can imagine that a lot of um
a lot of companies would be thinking
yeah someone else could include the
pregnant woman in their trial because we
don't want to to have the trial that
messes up
yeah so so i mean i i think this goes
back to the where we need better
collaboration between the industry
between researchers and and clinical you
know providers and also the regulatory
authorities because there is an approach
you can take which safeguards that the
mother and the unborn child in doing
research but it it the onus can't be
just on the pharmaceutical company to
deliver that it has to be a an agreed
approach on how best to do this and and
and also i suppose with the risks
involved where we need to do it you know
from that perspective but as louise said
i think it all first starts also with
with grassroots research being put into
it from that perspective and we also
want to add is also when we talk about
prevention what we also need to talk
about is is there is obviously
a therapy area related prevention but
then also we we uh rely on primary care
to to to to sort of soak up the rest of
general public health prevention right
and the and the way that our
commissioning system works currently
today is that if you're up say i don't
know a hiv physician who wants to give a
vaccine to your hiv patient you'll have
to refer them back to primary care to
have that vaccine whereas you know it's
easier in the old system where
me being a hiv physician where i could
be able to give that vaccine there and
then because i felt my patient was under
risk so i think we need to look at the
how flexible and louis sort of mentioned
the word agile we are in in funding
streams to allow different professions
and different specialties to take a
broader perspective on on prevention
from that perspective and i think
finally that is doable that if you look
at things like hpv vaccination scheme
that is over time now delivering a
reduced amount to cervical cancer right
so
and louise's point of india sort of fun
savings versus savings in healthy
outcomes over years is is really
important it's something we need to
adopt more and more of you know
it's um it it becomes a
there's a huge uh political challenge uh
i think uh in this assuming limited
resources or um
it's how you deploy those resources and
fundamentally
in if you have limited resources how can
whether it's at the national level or
more local level
if you're redirecting resources where
the vast majority at the moment is kind
of end of life towards the end of life
if you're taking a proportion of those
resources away and eric can get at uh
young families uh or or pregnant women
that's a big decision to make uh when
people are going to be reacting to the
health care that they're offered at the
moment so i i i think it's the right
broadly the right way to go uh those
early interventions but it's a very
challenging decision to actually make
well i'm afraid uh that we have run out
of time i know that all four of us could
have gone on for several more hours and
thank you so much to to all three of you
to louise cham and chris for joining me
on this panel about the future of
british healthcare and how we can become
a life science superpower we've had so
much food for thought thank you so much
to msd for sponsoring at this really
important discussion and to all of you
at home thank you so much for watching
and for your really interesting
questions i'm sorry we weren't able to
get through all of them but we i think
we had a really meaty discussion so
thank you for your contributions
to that now you can re-watch any part of
this discussion on spectator tv shortly
after the live stream ends and we hope
to see you on another spectator event in
the near future thank you everyone for
taking part